Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
I'm Justin and back in December I told
you guys that if you left any comments,
questions, concerns, suggestions,
et Cetera, on a video,
I did ask him for them that I would get
around to answering them and January or
so and so here we are in mid January,
looking at the rest of 2018 a few things
I want to discuss before I get to your
actual question.
So firstly,
two of the most common complaints I get
is that I talk too quickly and I talked
to monotonously.
I agree that's been an issue and
I understand that this is a pain,
especially to people who don't
speak English as a first language,
but I've made use of this criticism and
I take my narration in my videos over
recent months has improved significantly.
Though of course I will continue to
improve on my narration skills as the
channel progress's.
Secondly,
another complaint that I get is that I
have an agenda or a bias in my videos.
I get these comments particularly on
obviously political or historical videos
and things like that.
I really don't think that I do to
the extent that people accused me of,
I think that's just something that anyone
on youtube we'll get accused of when
they discuss controversial subjects.
And I think the most that assures me
that I'm not letting a bias slip into my
videos is that I have videos for example,
that have been called both rightwing
trash and left this nonsense.
It's not really correct to say that
I leave my opinions out of my videos.
I will admit to a number of things,
like I might say,
unfortunately 500 people died in
this event and someone might think
unfortunately is that uh,
it was an opinion on the
matter will yet be caught me.
I think death is unfortunate,
but beyond that I only really
add my personal opinions
to things when I think it
would help a lesson.
Like I may,
like I may overtly state that I think
philosophy is as important as science.
That's a video that I did
on a complete opinion,
but stating my opinion opens the door.
Let's stay in the opinion and making the
argument that I made opens the door for
a large amount of philosophical
conversations to take
place on this channel.
Furthermore, I don't subliminally
just insert my opinions into videos.
My opinions on things when I share them
are right up front and I encourage you
guys to disagree with me because I
think debate helps the learning process.
Most importantly,
I avoid sharing my opinions on them on
politics or economics or a number of
social or religious or whatever issues.
I'm not afraid to talk about these things.
We've talked about them already
quite frequently, but when I do,
I make an effort to
present all sides equally,
fairly and objectively and often
even when I do share my opinion,
I do give fair consideration to
the opposite argument. Why a,
you guys aren't coming here
to consider me for Congress.
You're here to talk about some cool stuff
slipping in my own perspective as fact
just makes it unappealing.
You know, that being said,
if it seems like I make a mistake or it
seems like I inserted buys or you don't
understand something,
tell me in the comments.
If you're mad that I'm not pandering
to your specific view of things,
that that's just too bad.
You're going to have to get over that.
That's not how I work and that's
not fair or intellectually honest.
Take it somewhere else,
but if I am doing something wrong,
I appreciate your guys',
his corrections.
I make an effort to listen to you guys
and be bias information is all that's out
there these days. You go to
school, maybe you read the news,
you watch other youtube channels and
there's just an obvious amount of half
truths and bias and flat out lies and
things like that that are intentionally
inserted to reinforce some agenda and
not to just talk about something for its
own sake. It's not hard to see. In
fact, it's hard to get away from,
I don't know about you,
but it pisses me off when people can be
intellectually dishonest with a straight
face. You can't trust anything and
I'm not saying it's all one side.
Every side seems to do it.
Even people I agree with it seem to do it,
but I still think it's wrong.
Fire of learning is a small channel,
but I like to think that we are unique
in an approach of meat or at least
uncommon in an approach of
me just attempting to present
information objectively
and fairly and not trying to get in the
way of you thinking for yourself while a
lot of other channels out there,
even other educational channels
really don't respect that.
You know their presents,
similar information that makes similar
videos but they want you to think about
things from a certain perspective
and I think that's dumb.
I think people who go out of their way
to watch educational youtube videos are
smart enough to think for themselves.
Anyway,
that was probably kind
of a long side rant,
but I felt it was necessary
to reiterate bottom line,
some of my opinions do come out. I think
philosophy is as important as science.
I think colonizing Mars would be great.
I think Picard is the better captain,
but I do make an effort to make my
videos fair and objective and I think my
opinions don't get in the way,
or at least I hope they do not
have you thinking for yourself.
The only agenda here at fire learning as
promoting the idea that education makes
the world go round and that understanding
the universe is one of the most
important pursuits of life any way.
Now to your specific questions,
Mark Benjamin,
you have three comments here.
The first explain the difference between
the schools of economics. Secondly,
can you teach cryptocurrency and financial
slash bank history including gold and
silver? Thirdly, would you be,
would you be having a
steam@dotcomormines.com
channel your first question?
Yes. Economics is something
I haven't really gotten into
much beyond my political
compass video,
but it is something I have been meaning
to cover just because economics is so
central to how we live our lives and
how the world works. Second, absolutely.
I actually own some bitcoin and
silver and that sort of thing.
I'd be glad to make some videos on those
topics and their histories. Thirdly,
I'm not familiar with those websites.
I could look into them,
but I have a fire of learning Facebook
and Instagram that I admittedly only semi
keep up with, so not entirely
sure what I'll be doing with that.
I guess Tj Johnson, thanks for
what you do. Live long and prosper.
Thank you TJ. Live long and
prosper as well. Maria. Colin,
my life moves at a pace faster
than that of the Internet,
so unfortunately I do not have any
useful intelligence for you at this time.
The Best I can offer you is good luck
and keep doing what you're doing.
Thank you Maria. I appreciate
that. Don't move too fast though.
Be sure to stop and smell
the roses sometimes.
Devonish Cytopenia I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly.
The first video I watched was top 10
lessons by Niccolo Machiavelli after that
or realize that you have a video about
evolution as well and that wasn't really
a good representation.
I really appreciate the content you
post and the inflammation is of great
quality and helpful.
Now I want to talk about a few
things that I felt could be better.
Your representations mostly
consists of pictures,
although it's debatable
that people might like that,
but I felt switching to videos would
be a great improvement if you could.
I would also suggest that you add
some background ambient music.
It goes a long way and makes me get my
eyes and mind peeled into the video.
I hope you take the
suggestions constructively.
I really liked his channel.
I hope you keep making amazing and
informative videos like these video ideas.
One top three or five strangers,
planets were stars and the local group
or Milky Way Galaxy or the universe to
you could start a series on a particular
topic like about great minds like
Nikola Tesla,
Alan Watts and others.
Three top 10 innovations that changed
the world for a top 10 books for
personality development or to rethink
our lifestyle. They get a bunch.
I appreciate that.
Regarding the pictures,
I'm not going to lie this things with
the thing with pictures of that they're
easier to use.
I have used videos for space or history
of videos and that in a few of my videos,
but the thing is that they are much more
protected and liked to get taken down.
I've considered making my own videos in
terms of like drawings or me speaking on
camera,
but I'm not much of an artist and the
pictures are more interesting and helpful
than just me and my room
for an entire 30 minutes.
If you guys would be cool with it,
I could like get some friends together
and go out into the field and dress up as
mongers or something from an
ex history video, make a film,
something with my phone
camera or something like that.
Music is similar situation.
Not a lot of royalty free stuff out there.
I have used it in the past
but implementing it in a 50
minute video or something
like that would be just difficult.
But if you guys want me to I could handle
that. I like those video ideas. The,
I think the top 10 tips videos that I do
do a decent job on the surface level of
exploring how some great minds thought,
but I would be glad to do entire videos
on like very influential and profound
people throughout history
like biography type videos.
I did one on Isaac Newton way back in
2015 if you can handle my early narration
skills and the awful audio quality,
but the information
itself is a decent enough.
David [inaudible] I subscribed because
I liked your history videos and it would
be great to see more of them,
but I've enjoyed some of your
linguistics and space videos too.
I'm not as interested in your more
American stuff like politicians,
Saint Patrick, Halloween,
US history, et Cetera,
but I'm Australian so it's
fairly irrelevant to me. Anyway,
thanks for all your great work.
Thank you David.
That's a very great comment because I
was actually meaning to mention that I
obviously am an American.
A lot of my viewers are from the USA.
A few of my videos are targeted
specifically to an American audience,
but I do my best to keep in mind that
I am speaking to an international
community,
so videos that appeal to Australians
and New Zealanders and Englishman and
Canadians and such are on their
way along side the American side.
Videos that I do,
I definitely do have more history but
it was coming and I have actually been
thinking about doing some stuff on the
history of Australia and New Zealand and
stuff like that because a sizable amount
of my viewers are such as herself from
those countries.
Christian Rayez.
I know that you already
tread on the NBTI path,
but I would really like it if you could
do actually do videos on individual
types.
I found her other type
videos so illuminating that
I would like to hear a more
in depth analysis on specific NBTI
types or even type comparisons.
Eg I NFJ versus IFP. Thank
you for that. Christian.
I tried to highlight aspects of individual
types in the group videos that I did,
but I could definitely do some
videos on individual types as well.
I also liked the idea of type
comparisons that could be interesting.
I did an overview of the entire NBTI
subject as a kind of introduction to
personality psychology and journalists
since it was something that was popular
among people and it's something that
I like and have very much locked into.
My defense video in particular
was partially me saying, you know,
the NBTI isn't just astrology for
people who watch Rick and Morty.
It isn't perfect,
but it has some substance to it,
some credibility it's worth looking at,
but it was also partially me responding
to an even bigger nonsense idea that you
can't quantify personality.
There are people,
and I displayed them in the video who are
tearing apart a lot of what psychology
shows for no valid reason other
than what is, in my opinion,
trying to avoid hurting people's feelings,
which is not to be tolerated in science,
but anyway,
I'm not going to ramble on about that.
I just wanted to say that the NBTI stuff
was a part of a much larger project of
psychology that I want
to cover on this channel.
What I want to do with the NBTI from here
is to look at why people are the ways
that they are, why we have the personality
traits we do. You know for, you know,
your example in IFP in
and I have Jay and I,
NFP is an introverted feeler
and inf j as an extroverted via,
but why do those differences
exist? What is, for example,
what we call introverted feeling?
Why do the characteristics that make up
what we define as introverted feeling
exist? What's going on in the brain?
What personality traits are we born with?
What do we develop?
How do these types compare to something
like the big five or other models and
things of that nature.
But yes,
definitely videos like the
ones who suggested here are
definitely in the future.
Chest and Blankenship,
I'd like to see some more things over
more modern wars like world war two and
the evolution of languages.
Modern wars in history,
absolutely very relevant
and very important,
especially in what we choose
to do with our futures.
I have plans to address recent history
coming up pretty soon actually.
Evolution of languages.
I love languages and I love the evolution
of languages and at a mall g and
things like that. I've talked about
pieces of the history of some languages,
like particularly English
and several of my videos,
probably the most I've done analyzing
the history of English specifically is in
my video is English the
hardest language to learn.
But I honestly hate that video because
it's cringy and dumb and I honestly on to
keep it up because my girlfriend and joy's
it for that reason. But other videos,
looking at languages and things
like that are definitely coming.
Joseph Mcdevitt to know nothing of what
happened before you were born is to
remain forever a child. Cicero, keep up
the good work. Very well said. Joseph,
thank you.
I will try to do so Aaron,
maybe do some more NBTI videos
to get some subscribers,
maybe debunking some conspiracy
theories or flat earth.
I think that should bring some strange
people in Austin. Maybe not personally.
I would like an evolution one,
a one series. Like I said,
I'll be mentioning the NBTI
and the future for sure,
and I'll be talking more broadly
about psychology for sure.
If you guys want more videos
on the NBTI specifically,
I'd be happy to make them
conspiracy theories. Well, you know,
strange people come around no matter what.
That's just the beauty of the Internet.
People can be more vocal here than in
person and that includes strange people.
Something like the flat earth isn't
really believed by a concerning amount of
people,
but I still be glad to debunk it.
Conspiracy theories like
that are interesting and
that they make you think, oh,
how can we be sure that
the earth has around?
And you learn a little bit
from that question. That
initially seems nonsensical.
So a video on the subject is worthwhile,
even if it's not a serious threat
to messing with the population.
Probably more concerning conspiracy
theories are those surrounding water
fluoridation or GMOs or things like that.
And I do plan to address those things
regardless of the interesting people that
they will attract.
I mean,
interesting people have already
been attracted to channel. There's,
there's no going back.
Evolution.
One O one biology is one
of my favorite subjects.
Genetics is one of my favorite subjects.
Videos like that are definitely
on the way. Frank COPCO,
I would love to learn about the
history of Prussia. Slash Brandenburg.
I was born in Berlin and have seen
difficulty in finding history in Australia
about this.
It seems that the German people and
historians in that part of the world are
still being browbeaten over World War II
and are therefore reticent to speak of
expansionist policies.
I find especially in your histories,
English one in particular that you are
very fair and even in your summation of
attributing blame for World War One
and World War II and therefore eagerly
anticipate your postings.
Thank you for a great year of learning a
day spent without learning something is
a day wasted. Happy New
Year. Docushare and frank,
I would very much like to
do a history on pressure.
It's a similar situation here in the
United States where when you say German
history people only think of world war
one and two but German history extends as
you know of course long before that and
that history deserves to be remembered.
So yes, definitely something coming
on that. I appreciate the compliment.
I try my hardest to be as fair as
possible. Happy New Year to you as well.
Mr M your video is our appreciative
sir. Thank you. Thank you mister em.
I appreciate that there are more videos
on the way Gordon do more videos like
the one on England,
the full history of countries and
empires existing and fallen. For example,
the Normans as I speak.
I actually have a full history video of
a nation like the one I did with England
and the works and I plan on making
plenty more throughout the year.
The Normans I've talked about in my
viking documentary and my England
documentary though I've never
really focused on them individually,
but I can definitely
do that in the future.
They're an interesting topic to cover,
but yeah,
expect to see more full history videos
coming up and expect to see one soon.
Jakey d 25 I really like your videos.
Thank you. Thank you, Jackie Dia.
I appreciate that there
are plenty more on the way.
Thank you for all those
comments, questions and
concerns and things like that.
If you guys have thought of any more the
comments section in this video and all
my other ones are always open.
I tried to read as many comments as I
can and if you guys want me to do another
like Q and a type thing I would definitely
be open to doing is promoting is like
this and videos on many other subjects.
Be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.